Unfortunately, we don't know what
kind of result will be returned
by the place picker.
If we get a place, we know that we'll
have an address, but that address could
be anything, from a city name to
a business name, or even empty string.
So we can't reliably form a request
to the weather service off of this
string alone.
However, a place object also
contains a latitude and a longitude.
And open weather map supports
queries by LatLong, so
what we need to do is to store
the address as our location string, but
store the LatLong as our location query.
To do this,
let's begin with the simple things.
First, we need to declare two
new preference keys, one for
latitude and one for longitude.
Then we can create new utility
methods to help us out.
One each to get the value
of the latitude and
longitude out of their preferences.
And then a third method to check for
the existence of these preferences.
And these preferences will be our
indicator that we are using a place
picker location, instead of
a user entered string location.
If the user decides to replace their
location with the string later on, we'll
wipe these preferences, as a signal to
stop forming the query with a LatLong.
In sync adapter,
instead of always building the query
based off of the location string,
we want to, potentially,
build the query using a LatLong value.
So first, we need to check if
we have a LatLong to work with.
And if we do, we're going to build
the request using LAT and LON.
However, if we don't,
we're going to build it the way we were
before, using our location string.
The rest of the URI
builder remains unchanged.
However, since we are dependant on
the existence of a LatLong preference,
as a signal that we are using
a place picker location, we need to
wipe those preferences when the user
enters the location string manually.
So in settings activity in,
onSharedPreferenceChanged,
you'll need to do this whenever
the location is updated.
This method is an automatic callback
that is invoked by the dialog
preference class.
Because our place picker was an intent
launched by settings activity,
it won't ever trigger this call back.
And so, this is a safe place to
reliably wipe the Place Picker LatLong,
whenever we have a manual entry.
Because we don't trigger their callback
when returning from the Place Picker,
we'll need to tell our sync adapter that
something has changed in on activity
result.
First, we'll update the preference
summary string in our settings UI, and
then we'll ask our sync adapter
to fetch new weather data.
This should all happen after
the new preferences are written.
And that is why we use commit,
instead of apply,
when we're writing to
our shared preferences.
Commit ensures that the preferences
are ready in time for our sync it after
update, whereas, apply is asynchronous,
and can't make the same guarantee.
Now as for, actually, writing the long
preferences, I'm leaving that to you.